Okay, you're going to the,
you're covering the Winter Olympics.
Yes!
Oh my God, I'm so excited!
(audience cheer and clap)
I know, I know.
It's so fun.
Is there anyone that you're so excited for?
There's a million people!
It's gonna be great.
I mean, usually the whole "Today Show" goes to the Olympics.
Because of COVID, I know.
I remember you went to Japan
Yes
and they toured you around in the bus.
Yes! We did a, oh,
yes, COVID has changed the Olympics
just like it changes everything.
But not the competition.
So The Today Show is actually going to
basically do an Olympic Plaza.
We're gonna have athletes come by.
Fire pits.
We're gonna like do it up on the show
so you can cover, you know,
follow all the Olympics.
But I'm really looking forward to,
I love figure skating.
Me too!
I'm sorry, it's my favorite!
My favorite!
Do you remember?
There was a, a skater named Nathan Chen,
and in Pyeongchang,
he was the guy that everyone was like,
he's going to medal, he's perfect.
Yes.
He did not have the results he, he wanted.
And it was a huge disappointment.
And do you know what he's done
pretty much every competition since then?
Ace it.
He's won.
And he's back.
And I really am just so rooting for him.
I want him to have his redemption.
Well, and I swear, if there's anything better
than an Olympic package
that's a background story on people,
you get so invested.
That is the best storytelling ever!
Well all of these Olympians,
every single one has an incredible story.
To get there takes so much determination,
so much grit.
Everyone's overcome obstacles.
There's not anyone who hasn't put their heart,
their soul, everything on the line,
day after day, year after year, for this one second.
So the, you don't even have to manufacture any drama.
It's right there.
You don't.
And it's also like, these are just,
these are good, hardworking, talented people,
who poured themselves into a goal.
And it's so fun to watch them shine!
I just love it.
When I watch with the girls, I, the whole time,
I keep saying to them like the pressure is that
everything leads up to this moment.
You can work for five years,
and it is judged within five minutes.
Ugh.
And that, to put yourself in that kind of line of work,
That's pressure.
The craziest!
I don't know how they do it, honestly.
I don't know,
but I can't wait to see you take us through it all.
And I have to before,
(audience applauds)
Okay.
You have a new show that we're going to go to commercial,
and we're going to come back and talk all about.
'Cause I'm so excited for this show.
I watched the first episode.
You should come on the cooking show.
I want to!
You can teach me to cook.
You have a cookbook!
I do, and mine's, Rebel Homemaker,
and your is Starting From Scratch.
Yes. We're going it.
I also want to come on really badly!
So wait a minute.
Tattoo. Cooking show.
What else can we do?
(upbeat happy music)